i'm finished this is the last review on
hunter hunter i will be doing for at
least a little bit and
looking at the recent output from
takashi i would imagine for
quite some time but fret not because
daddy mark's got some juicy content here
for you today
and a celebration of sorts for my new
favorite moment in the series
there are moments like this in
practically every story worth telling
and in one way or another these moments
end up defining their story's legacies
the chaos fear and power that was seen
during goku vs frieza the heartbreak and
loss that was experienced through the
thanos snap
and the selfish geometric breaking
idiocy that was jack leaving rose on the
piece of driftwood big enough for both
of them
but my point is all of these are stories
that in one way or another etched their
names onto our collective consciousness
and this week my eyes bore witness to
and
fully realize the moment that i welcome
to echo in my mind as the single most
cathartic experience
in all of hunter hunter's long and
winding story for me i am of course
talking about
let's watch that again
all right feels good let's watch that
again
let's do this
i loved this arc i just want to open
with that because
there are believe it or not people who
genuinely believe that just because i
didn't enjoy a hefty chunk of the khmer
and sark that it must mean that i now
hate this series regardless of what
negatives i've taken from this series
it's also been a tale that's made me cry
made me laugh and made me cheer like a
freaking madman this is a story that
while having instances where i didn't
love
every little detail still provided me
with a series that challenged and
captured my imagination and yes while
the greed island and chimera ants
arcs weren't the arcs for me per se they
managed to facilitate a return to what i
loved about this series the most
serious subject matter with a careful
amount of comedy and a goal
i can absolutely get behind this arc
that i'm about to review today
while doing nothing complicated really
helped to capture
exactly what it is about hunter hunter
that i personally adore
and spoiler alert this one got me a
little emotional too
so let's see if you guys can guess which
part got me let's see who knows me the
best so leave your predictions in the
comments and
no cheating right off the bat the two
major plot lines that operate as the
focus of this arc quickly established
their given goals either carrying it
over from the previous arc like killer
was adventure to save gone or perhaps
more interestingly the group of
hand-picked hunters known as the zodiac
tasked with helping facilitate the
selection of a new chairman after
natero's passing
and would you look who we got here some
things that came to my attention right
off the bat were the minor similarities
jing shares with gun
throughout this series gone has been in
some ways subtly or in other ways
overtly intelligent or
at the very least somewhat clever
finding solutions to problems in ways i
personally wouldn't have
ever thought of and in this material
jing shows off a much more refined
application for that cleverness he
understands these people he's working
alongside and for better or worse
manipulates them into doing what he
thinks is best whether it be by throwing
his name
in for the chairman consideration
lending advice here and there to others
or by taking a fat one to the face he's
by far and away the best part of these
chapters concerning these individuals
though he's not there for too long a
downside to these early chapters
concerning the election for me at least
were how pedantic they could be all the
while dealing with new characters
primarily with jing being the only
character in this material i have any
interest in when he's absent i
felt some sense of tedium when engaging
with this portion of the story
particularly as this aspect of the tale
deals primarily in bureaucracy however
unlike other arcs this didn't lack a
primary goal for me to latch onto
they are trying to select a new chairman
and all the while jing is present in the
material and besides the real question
hanging in the air is swirling around
the question
will gon recover and if he does will he
be in time to see his father something
that's been a goal of his from the very
start
something that i thought was a little
odd initially was the presence of a new
character called aluka killer was sister
she's pretty much the vehicle that makes
what happens in this arc possible and
when that sort of significance or
importance is thrust upon a character or
their abilities in this case both
ideally i would have liked that
character to have been known to us prior
whether it be their abilities or
individuality having spent time
at the zoldic family mansion in prior
arcs i thought this to be a strange and
somewhat contrived direction to go in
for the story that in some respects felt
as though it came out of nowhere though
i will admit that it was pointed out to
me earlier this week that aluko was
depicted early on in chapter 2 to zero
during the chimera ants arc in a
photograph
so i guess she was conceived of much
earlier in the story than she was needed
just not put into action or draw
attention to
speaking of the character i did enjoy
aluka quite a lot early on perhaps more
so than i thought i would her
personality
is drip-fed to us through the point of
view of kilauea whether it be through
flashbacks of them playing as kids or
perhaps most importantly her dynamic
with her wider family takashi made an
interesting choice in communicating her
relationship with the rest of her family
and having everyone outside of kinaba
refer to her as
he him or master with killua being the
only person who refers to her as
her this was a welcomed and interesting
means of communicating their
relationship in a snappy and efficient
fashion because really this arc's pacing
is great it doesn't waste
any time however i think what helped
this arc flourish the most came in the
form of one character returning to the
spotlight
and that character is
[Music]
la oreo i recognize that for many
hardcore hunter hunter fans out there
for me to love leorio as much as i do
might come across as perhaps strange or
indicative of
me not properly appreciating the
material but i think i can rationalize
my position with respect to that
and maintain consistency with my
perspective on the series throughout
without layorio it is my belief that
this arc would not work for me at all
and that is not to say that there's
nothing else
in this arc that i love i mean
absolutely not i love numerous scenes
lyorio had nothing to do with
however if you were to remove leorio
from this arc it's my belief that the
rest of it would suffer greatly
so let me explain in prior videos i have
touched on what it is about films tv
shows and stories that makes us
laugh cry or become emboldened to emote
passionately now obviously there are a
number of ways to achieve this effect
but the most effective for me
that i've found has been in the pursuit
of contrast take the final battle in one
piece of sabaudi archipelago for example
we've followed this gang through thick
and thin no matter what stood in their
way
they've always come out on top and
manage to save each other from certain
disaster
and moments before this encounter in the
archipelago they were laughing
joking around and then engage in some
tremendous heart-stopping action
and as if mere candles were being
extinguished or a light switch was being
flicked off
one by one they are torn away from luffy
seemingly never to be seen again now
what made that scene as emotional as it
was for me
has to be the sudden shift from
togetherness hope and optimism
to isolation despair and negativity it's
a striking and potent contrast that
really hammers home the significance of
that moment
and their relationship it's the sudden
spike that massive tonal shift that does
it for me this can take place in a
sudden realization and
in the opposite direction even wherein
characters go from despair to happiness
also this is
effectively the essence of the film your
name and particularly the final moments
where we think they might not actually
get together and when they do
there's that relief and contrast i see
it i cry for an hour roll credits but
again i want to reiterate that this
isn't the only way to achieve this
effect in people we're all different and
as a result different approaches work
and don't work for each of us
and while i don't want to touch on this
for too long because i did enjoy most of
the major beats in this story the
chimera anne's arc felt extremely
negative to me for prolonged durations
of time with little to no breaks
i understand that that's sort of the
point as the subject matter deals with
some truly horrific material and perhaps
a lighter touch might not have been
appropriate but this is predominantly
the reason i didn't find it as potent
and experienced as i'm sure many of you
who loved it
might have found the philosophy is
interesting but nothing i haven't
explored through conversation into the
late hours of the night with my closest
friends
and the tone while interesting and
effective in its framing of events
feels at least compared to the rest of
the story somewhat
one note by the time the chimera king
died i understood that this was
obviously a sad moment but it didn't
even remotely affect me like many of you
described it would
there was no history for me to look back
on with the character outside of some
murders and a lot of fun board games and
while those were nice and enjoyable the
relentlessly grim affair that was this
arc
ended up making these final moments feel
less sad by contrast
he's already dead but somewhat
interestingly
while the arc didn't invoke any strong
feelings for me in terms of reaction
it did spiral me into a nihilistic abyss
for a solid two weeks forcing me to
question whether or not i should or
should not finish the series but
in the end my psychotic compulsion to
complete what i set out to finish
flew in the face of any dwindling mental
health i had at the time and you know
what jokes aside i'm actually glad it
did because
this arc injected back into hunter
hunter what i loved about the series
there was once again a sense of
camaraderie painting the walls of every
encounter whether it be through kilowatt
doing everything in his power to protect
his sister and save gun or
in the case of these scenes they brought
back leorio and choosing to include him
in this material carried for me the
second of the two major plot points
in this arc for me his offbeat goofiness
combined with his love for his friend
really contrasted beautifully with the
mundane boring bureaucracy the rest of
this section brandishes and in a way
sort of reminded me of how loki
complements the
bureaucracy of the tva in marvel's loki
if you haven't seen it already quick
plug it's a great show needless to say
this enhanced for me a number of
characters in the story but none more so
than jing and with gonous
laying somewhere in intensive care
elsewhere i was hoping and praying that
finally now that this gene character is
staying
in one known place for extended periods
of time it would be amazing if kilauea
could find a way to help his friend
recover so that he could
you know see his dad
[Music]
normally in circumstances like these
when some previously unknown mechanic is
made possible through some otherwise
unknown person in order to revive
someone we thought was lost
normally this would bother me to such an
extent that i would have a difficult
time enjoying the rest of the story but
really this alika plotline is handled
superbly well
we learn of our interesting and honestly
frightening set of powers and the
equivalent exchange that seems to go
hand in hand with them
you ask for one thing and she shall
grant it for you but then you need to do
three things for her in order to balance
the spreadsheet so to speak she's
effectively the means by which gone
makes a miraculous recovery during this
material and if that's all there was to
this encounter
then you'd be hearing a very different
song being sung by me right now but
thankfully there's much more meat to
this plot thread and one that leans
heavily into the themes of family and
abuse kilauea's character has been
exploring since the beginning unlike the
rest of his family kilowatt cares deeply
about his sister and will do anything
for her well-being reading through
flashbacks which capture the early
moments of their toxic familial
relationship altering alaka's treatment
are both harrowing
scary and emotionally powerful
particularly when we fully come to grips
with how they've been treating her all
this time
symbolically this is the most overt
defiance of his family's wishes kilauea
has performed thus far and it's for the
benefit of another again a terrific
contrast with the scared individual that
would be afraid to overextend himself
particularly evident in the first act
when confronted by his brother illumi
being the most evident of this and as
kilowatt to his face defies him time and
again in this arc it's supremely
satisfying and what's more is that
kilauea uses this relationship with
allocate to
outmaneuver and out think his oppressive
family aiding in his escape of the
compound on route to the hospital
housing gone
as mentioned above there are two
separate plot threads running side by
side here
and neither are connected until the very
very end of the story the first being
kilauea's rescue and ultimate delivery
of aluca to gohan's bedside to heal him
all the while running from
and the second is
once leorio arrives at the scene during
the q a for the chairman voting
situation he is the first to hop up to
the podium and asks a rather pointed
question towards
jing asking the very question we've
wanted to ask all along
why hasn't he even attempted to see his
son and unsatisfied with the answer
leorio unveils to us
and jing his nan type catching him off
guard with a massive punch of the face
this was and i cannot begin to express
how much love i had for it upon first
reading if this isn't one of the best
moments in the series i don't know
what is and this sequence pretty much
sets the trend in place for the rest of
this half of the story leorio plays a
leading role in injecting just the right
amount of heart and humor
into the story to allow me to enjoy the
rest of the material as much as i did
i mean lyorio's indifference to being
chairman at the hunter association
coupled with his preposterous popularity
cemented him as my favorite character in
this series
he's just so much fun and i'm not even
done talking about him in this section
yet
but first let's finish off kilowatt's
story with aluka
zorodik
[Music]
due to the flashback nature of alako's
ability illumi takes the initiative and
attempts to kill his brother
before he can make a wish with aluca
regardless of how i may or may not feel
about alako coming into the story her
involvement offered a great mechanism
that pushes kilauea and his family into
conflict
this arc pulled a lot of weight that i
honestly wasn't expecting with the first
being a terrific capping off to killua's
character arc
once a young man petrified by the very
sight of his brother illumi and now he's
strategizing to outmaneuver and defy him
at
every possible turn and not really in an
effort to affirm anything necessarily
about himself or to raise his own
standing
instead it is for the benefit of his
sister and his best friend in the world
this sequence from the car chase the
involvement of the butlers their
conflicting allegiances
and the strategy from kilauea employing
the hot air balloons all the while alaka
provides numerous instances of scare
and horror made for a brilliant action
sequence that had me captivated from the
beginning to the very end with of course
the clear highlights of this section
coming by way of any direct involvement
from hisoka
or illumi but perhaps most significantly
what i loved about this sequence was how
it highlighted the greatest strengths
gone has
his ability to make lasting and powerful
relationships with people his ability to
make friends with kilauea ended up
making the surge of power he gained to
kill pito
possible to return from and his bond
with lyorio had him in the running for
winning chairman of the hunters
association and would have given him the
power to dedicate all resources of the
association to his recovery
and all of this happens within the arc
we anticipate he will meet his father
someone that not too long ago lamented
overgone's reliance on his friends
citing that trait as a weakness in him
overall it's a powerful and satisfying
merging of themes
eventually killable reaches gone's
bedside and it cuts to leorio's
continued success in the race
and in the middle of another speech
where he expresses his concern
and sense of powerlessness to help gone
the young hunter barges into the
auditorium leading leorio to embrace him
tightly
this moment was so sweet that i actually
welled up a little bit and yes this was
the moment that got me emotional if you
commented that down below
congratulations you know me very well
this was exactly the sort of stuff that
i was missing from hunter hunter
kurapika layorio and kilauea made such a
brilliant team of clashing personalities
that once it became almost entirely
about killaba and gonz dynamic that very
dynamic became a little less special
which was a shame because
i do love those characters and while
kurapika isn't in this arc at all
the tone and power of this arc was
helped immeasurably by lyorio the last
two chapters where gon finally gets to
share more than a fleeting exchange with
his father is a fitting end to what has
been a long story told over the course
of 339 chapters
while i personally didn't like jing as a
person i don't think it was important
that i did or did not
and the final panels of gon's time spent
with jing focused not on jing's
happiness or their collective joy
together
though that is definitely present here
and there primarily what i felt this arc
focused on towards the end
was the wonder and joy gone feels in
that moment with his dad
he's achieved what he set out to do from
the very beginning and in a way
that's so cathartic and powerful and
emotional and brilliant to me
to open up a bit i've got a rather
complicated family history and it's one
that i've been
very conscious was painting my
expectations and reactions to most parts
of the story from the beginning when i
was
three years old my parents divorced
leaving me to bounce between homes as
they both wanted to be in my life
i didn't mind this at all and really i
consider my childhood to be a very
secure and happy one i was very lucky i
do however have a younger brother seven
years younger in fact
one my mother had with another partner
after and long story short he left when
my brother was just one year old
and to this day we've never seen him
again and growing up it sort of put me
into a
strange role something akin to half a
brother and half a father once i got old
enough and reading through this story
looking at what gone was going through
how he was feeling and what sort of
clumsy and unkind treatment ching placed
in front of him all because he either
didn't want to engage or was nervous to
invoke strong and personal feelings i
had regarding that situation in my real
life
so when i say that i loved hunter hunter
i'm not saying that just to appease an
audience i know
loves the series also i sincerely mean
it as it gave me an avenue to better
explore my own complicated feelings
surrounding my family's history and the
love i have for my brother
for outsiders looking in i think it's
easy to look at a situation like this
objectively and see it for what it is
but when people you love are involved
and
waters are muddied suddenly the right
choice of action isn't obvious and it
becomes a series of compromises and
trade-offs
hunter hunter explored all of those in
great detail through a variety of
different avenues coming to a head
during the traumatic and devastating
chimera ants arc and thankfully climbed
out of that despair and injected the
hope and optimism
i looked to these stories initially for
and so in an effort to subvert the genre
consistently
it for me managed to create one of the
most cathartic shonen moments i've yet
read through unlike other stories i
don't think hunter hunter is one that
can be fully captured and realized
without digesting at all
and while i'm aware that kurapika's
story continues on after this
the heart of this tale for me was gone
and to see his story meet a fittingly
heartwarming conclusion in a series that
has been described as
notoriously grim and incomplete was one
of the most beautiful surprises
i've ever received from a manga maybe
this story will continue maybe it won't
but whether it does or it doesn't has no
impact
on how happy i am to have read it and to
have shared it with all of you these
last few months
as always i've been told not mark i'll
see you all next weekend
thank you so much for watching
[Music]
[Music]
you